more more or more less probably more or
less he said no he said no man I
don't know who you are but whoever
you're looking for
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there
I'm in you are hey youtubers is charlie
this is gonna be my ranking of Justice
League teams in the comics we're about a
year away from the movie there have been
so many different versions of the team
in the comics so for most of DC comics
history since the Silver Age Justice
League has been like the ticket to the
show like when you get called to the
Justice League that's the highest level
you can get to but the very first time
that the Justice League as we know it
now came together was in a title called
brave in the bold number 28 that the
famous cover that you've seen of them
fighting star oh now for the most part
canonically that is the original Justice
League but later things like the new 52
more recent like rebirth have retconned
characters in and out so for like a
period during the 80s the original
Justice League team got retconned so
that it said that Black Canary was a
founding member and Wonder Woman was not
but then later during the new 52 they
retconned Wonder Woman back in they've
also swapped cyborg in for Martian
Manhunter
so like Martian Manhunter was a founding
member of the Justice League but then
later they retcon cyborg and so you kind
of have to add like a little asterisk
like a little notation next to original
Justice League when you go see the movie
next year now it's going to be really
cool cyborg is still a cool character
Black Canary is still a really cool
character too but pretty much every best
version of the Justice League there have
been many different rosters all the best
versions have the Trinity on the team
with the exception of Justice League
dark so like everybody there were
periods of the comics where I didn't
read so I missed a couple of these teams
and then went back and read them later
like as they were being published
because I was a little kid during the
80s in the 90s so I will honor airily
call this original version number 10
because clearly I was not old enough to
have read this originally and I think a
lot of your favorite Justice Lee
teams just depend on when you started
reading comics but moving down the list
this is one of like the B rosters
Justice League United this was basically
a new 52 team led by Martian Manhunter
but one of the things the new 52 is most
famous for is trying to go super dark
super hardcore so naturally this
spin-off team was going to be more
hardcore than the original Justice
League anyway but add the new 52
creative on top of that and you have
like a stabby super crazy version of the
Justice League so as you can imagine not
quite as popular as the main title but
the team itself only lasted for about a
year they got destroyed during the
forever evil storyline but then you know
next one on the list
interesting idea a little more hardcore
a little more stabby but not quite as
cool there was something called the
Justice League elite pretty cool idea
but a little controversial just because
they were so much more stabby than you
would think a Justice League team would
be like there's certain things that all
heroes have in common and usually it's
not shooting people or stabbing people
in the face at every turn
so just chalk it up to a lot of the
darkness that was happening in the new
52 next is the post 52 relaunched
Justice League you can also think of him
as like the one year later Justice Lee
and the 52 title was around Final Crisis
not to be confused with the new 52
slightly different thing but also comics
had taken a slightly darker turn so this
was the team that came right after
identity crisis one of the most
controversial hated storylines in all of
DC Comics involving the Justice League
but this was the team where black Canary
first became the leader of the Justice
League those of you that watch Young
Justice and see the black black Canary's
in charge of the Justice League this is
the first time that officially happened
they also added Roy Harper vixen in
Black Lightning to the team a lot of you
may have heard that Greg Berlanti just
sold a Black Lightning TV show but I
think it's too fox it's not going to be
on the CW but there is a Black Lightning
TV show and obviously vixen is going to
be on legends of tomorrow season two
next I'll say Justice League
International was really cool idea it
was basically Maxwell Lord putting
together an all-star team of B level
heroes so like you have the Wally West
flash you have Guy Gardner you
have some of the a-listers like Batman's
on the team of course PF Booster Gold
Blue Beetle so this was during that time
so really fun idea that they later
repurposed during identity crisis the
story that I just mentioned where
Maxwell lore turns evil and you get like
super villain Maxwell Lord this was
during the time when he was not so much
the super villain next on the list is
what they kind of think of is the
satellite team during the crisis on
Infinite Earths era that was in like the
early 80s where you basically have like
a big team like a really big team living
on the Justice League Watchtower
satellite a lot of the way they wrote
that series the dynamics of the team as
well as the actual roster itself got
used as a template by later Justice
League writers select the more modern
incarnations or like the Grant Morrison
JLA team which I'll talk about it's a
little bit higher in my list that was
inspired in part by that satellite team
it also came during a really interesting
era in DC Comics so they were cleaning
up their history with crisis on Infinite
Earths next I'll say is the new 52
Justice League roster you know classic a
list trinity based roster but this was
the one that swapped in cyborg as a
founding member like said that he was a
founding member in not Martian Manhunter
and also put Wonder Woman back on the
team instead of Black Canary but even
though the artwork was good and it was
an interesting concept I just felt like
creative wasn't quite as good during the
new 52 in general so that's why it's not
like closer to the top of my list the
really interesting thing that they did
during the new 52 that they had not done
before was Captain Cold
became a member of the Justice League
and Lex Luthor they've been having a
little bit of fun with his character
more recently to the Lex Luthor
character like you may have seen him in
that Superman Kryptonian armor like it's
a big WTF twist next up on the list most
of you will probably know this as the
animated Justice League have seen at
least a couple of the movies they did if
it looks familiar like Batman the
Animated Series it's because Bruce Timm
worked on it Bruce Timm was one of the
creators of Batman the Animated Series
so this just kind of flowed out of that
animated universe you can actually catch
a lot of these animated movies either on
streaming services they rearm on TV all
the time but then I'll say a next
favorite is Justice League dark even if
the comic didn't pay off the way I
wanted it to I just really liked the
concept I like them taking a chance
but they are releasing the animated
Justice League dark movie when New York
comic-con happens so that's happening
like the next week you should be able to
watch that really soon
so it was all born during the new 52
like one of the really interesting ideas
from the new 52 even if everything
didn't pan out the way we wanted it to
so just can't wait to see what it looks
like in the live-action universe because
they are developing a live-action
Justice League dark so they say anything
cool about it I'll totally do a new
video about that but favorite Justice
League team is the Grant Morrison JLA
team so this is Tower of Babel era
Justice League it was sort of like Grant
Morrison coming along after a string of
b-list rosters saying I want to return
to the classic a list roster instill
this level of Mythology in the title
like Grant Morrison has the craziest
ideas and even if they seem kind of
weird you know is ins up being really
cool so I'll say Grant Morrison's
mythological Pantheon JLA is my favorite
Justice League roster but the thing is
is a lot of you know about tower Babel
it's an amazing Justice League story
very iconic but Mark Waid actually wrote
Tower of Babel you know they're doing a
lot of Mark Waid stuff on the flash
season 3 this year Mark Waid wrote Tower
of Babel not Grant Morrison so let me
know in the comments what is your
favorite Justice League roster I mean is
it like the classic ælis roster how do
you feel about them retconning
characters in characters I like do you
want to see Black Canary on Justice
League or do you like the cyborg and
Wonder Woman are in I feel like B you
know because of the way movies work you
want to go with like the biggest bang
for the buck yeah you have to put Wonder
Woman on the team and I think the reason
why they're not doing Martian Manhunter
1 because he's not quite as popular a
character right now as cyborg is because
you've already got Superman the alien on
the team they don't want to aliens like
they want everybody to feel as different
as possible so I will say
congratulations to this week's flash
giveaway winner Sakaki Richard you win a
gift certificate for the flash season 2
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there is a
new round that starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so what's
going to happen is there'll be new Game
of Thrones maybe some new Walking Dead
tomorrow there's new footage of season 7
so I might do new trailer video for that
but all the DC shows are coming back
really soon so there'll be a lot of DC
stuff dropping
next week just to get people hyped up we
also have Luke Cage that dropping agents
of shield Ghost Rider so if you're not
sure when stuff is coming I'll try to
remind everyone about Marvel stuff in
the Marvel videos DC stuff in the DC
videos so it's all going to be awesome
congratulations you made it this long
like you made it all summer now
everything is back while you guys wait
for my next video you can click here to
rewatch that flash trailer like a
billion more times and you can click
here to rewatch that Supergirl Superman
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you